cresson marot je reviens vers vous
qu'est ce qui a été décisif dans cette
élection
je crois que c'est quand même un
contexte très particulier à une crise
sanitaire comme le colis de 19 a quand
même été une épreuve pour beaucoup
d'entre nous donc je pense qu'on a on a
eu de la détermination on avait vraiment
une dynamique on avait une vraie équipe
solidaire compétentes rassembler
diverses et je pense que c'est ce cet
amalgame qui a réussi à à créer la
différence que l'on connaît dans les
résultats d'hier soir très saint marc où
est ce que les auxerrois vous voulez
vous où est-ce que d'une certaine
manière certains d'entre eux en tout cas
ne voulait plus du maire guy ferrer est
terrible bilan mais je pense vraiment
qu'il ya une il ya une adhésion on a
proposé quelque chose de nouveau quelque
chose de différent c'était assumé
c'était argumenté et j'ai quand même
l'impression que beaucoup de gens ont
dit qu'ils avaient envie de changement
envie de nouveauté envie de dynamisme et
je dis toujours qu'il faut convaincre et
de je pense qu'on a convaincu une
majorité de ces revoir alors comment
vous vous expliquiez ce changement
justement vous vous citiez le mot
dynamisme il vous semble qu'il faut
faire plus
il faut faire autrement comment
voulez-vous le définiriez j'ai dit
différent donc je pense qu'il faut le
faire différemment donc depuis le début
on dit qu'un territoire cédé en jeu et
il faut pas se tromper d'objectif il
faut commencer par bien identifier les
enjeux avant de parler de projet et
souvent fait linverse on parle de projet
on essaye de les intégrer dans dix ans
je et ensuite la vision transversale
d'un territoire c'est très important
donc c'est arrivé à faire converger les
enjeux et les projets pour ramener un
certain dynamisme d'un territoire
dynamisme économique dynamique
touristique dynamisme culturel dynamisme
sportif voilà que rosso servives on on
sait qu'il ya des dossiers dont on parle
depuis des années à auxerre je pense au
contournement sud on parle aussi de la
rénovation de l'arc bus par exemple vous
souriez pas ce qu'on a déjà échangé
autour des débats électoraux sur ces
sujets la fin est-ce que c'est des
dossiers que vous vous engagez à faire
avancer que vous allez reprendre que
vous allez revoir alors l'a dit mais la
déviation on est déterminés
à l'emmener jusqu'au bout et c'est
surtout aujourd'hui c'est l'incertitude
qui plane sur ce dossier là donc on veut
lever cette incertitude donc ça c'est
vraiment ce sera une déprime les
priorités à midi j'ai changé avec le
préfet donc je pense que dans les dix
jours qui viennent on aura un entretien
tous les deux justement on balaiera ces
grands dossiers du territoire donc le
marché d'arc but clairement tel qu'il
est fait on mettra un coup d'arrêt parce
qu'on n'est pas du tout absolument pas
d'accord dans les orientations qui ont
été prises par contre je sais qu'il ya
un débat sur le port par exemple et donc
ça c'est un dossier également qu'on
essaiera de prêter et puis un autre
sujet auquel je tiens beaucoup c'est la
liaison ferroviaire avec le grand paris
hier soir j'étais déjà en échange avec
valérie pécresse puisque je pense qu'il
ya un vrai un vrai lien un vrai avenir
pour l'auxerrois l'équipe de france
alors en quelques mots mais pour
terminer c'est plus personnel est ce que
vous étiez déjà dans les habits du maire
aujourd'hui dans cette première journée
alors j'ai déjà eu la chance d'être mère
donc c'est vrai que j'ai pas cette cette
nouveauté
donc je plutôt dans la continuité donc
j'ai entendu dans le reportage ce que
j'appellerais la continuté régaliennes
on n'est pas là pour tout révolutionner
bien au contraire il ya une obligation
de continuité mais on n'imprimera notre
marque quand même dans la façon dont on
va gouverner ce territoire je n'ai déjà
testé précédemment dans la commune de
saint-georges mer